so number one would have to be
batman forever go on for a joke yeah god
did we ran out of joke here john ran out
of movies
[Music]
what is up there reject nation the time
has come to do a ranking of the batman
theatrically released movies with a
couple of extended ones in there that
were not put in the cinemas i think the
easiest way to put it in perspective is
66 to 2022 or the films so if you guys
can leave a like that would be very much
appreciated we got like i think 15
movies i believe to run the gambit
through let's kick this off first one on
the list going from bottom to top
there's only a couple here i don't
really like batman and robin while i
know this has turned into like a cult
hit some consider it like a great spoof
or something like that and honestly
every time i turn this movie on the
first 10 to 20 minutes i'm thinking you
know what yeah this is gonna be a lot of
fun while i think arnold schwarzenegger
is a legend in this film i will
sometimes pull up compilations of what
he
says in this movie it's classic i hate
when people talk during the movie i can
never finish it i just can't even sit
through the film it quickly devolves
into just loud annoying and whatever
bemusement was to be had quickly just
dies for me and so yeah this very very
bottom for me johnny awesome very very
potent for me is batman v superman dawn
of justice the theatrical cut emphasize
the theatrical the theatrical cut don't
worry the extended version will be on
the screen elsewhere on the list but
yeah this movie wrecked my day when i
saw it i came out of the theater and i
was bummed out i was like this is an
expensive tentpole movie featuring two
of the most iconic characters there's no
excuse for it to be as unintelligible
and as unenjoyable as it turned out for
me so uh yeah this is probably the one
and only batman movie i truly dislike
all right so number 14 for emwar would
have to be batman forever the reason why
i put this above batman and robin is a
when i was young i actually liked the
movie when i was young i was like you
know what as a kid i thought it was good
and then when i got older especially the
last few times i've seen in recent years
i can confidently say i do not like this
film a lot of what i said about batman
and robin would definitely be applied to
here but i guess i give it the edge over
because there's actual cheese spread
throughout the film that i enjoy i
actually like val kilmer as bruce wayne
in the movie to be totally honest it's
uh kind of uncomfortably sexy i think
with nicole kidman i like chris
o'donnell but to be totally honest with
you guys i i don't like jim carrey's
performance in this movie and i don't
like tommy lee jones in here either i
think they're both very very annoying
and the last of the film just sort of
de-escalates into being very boring
so yeah not a big fan of this one
awesome well my next one on the list is
uh one of everyone's favorite batman
movies and that's the justice league the
theatrical cut of justice league what
hasn't been said about this movie
already it's a weird garish saturday
morning cartoon i don't actively dislike
it but i don't really have any reason to
watch it again and there's obviously a
much better version out there that i
would watch a thousand times again
before re-watching this it doesn't upset
me to the degree that like the bvs
theatrical cut did but i have no reason
to ever watch it again okay so number 13
for mwah would have to be batman v
superman dawn of justice the theatrical
cut i really didn't like this movie the
first time i saw it i thought it was
okay on rewatch still didn't really like
it too much yeah extended version will
be on this list already
while even in the theatrical version i
think ben affleck is great in the movie
i've always loved that warehouse fight
scene music choices i thought were good
and i think the opening has always been
fantastic despite some weird things
about that dude being in the building
jack
can't evacuate without direct orders
yeah i ultimately find the experience
like really hollow and and not in a
complementary way by any means i felt
very empty with most of the film all
right so number 13 for me would have to
be batman forever this is a movie that
teeters back and forth constantly for me
between scenes that i actually think are
kind of neat i agree i like val kilmer
as bruce wayne at least and yeah there
are some moments of actually funny humor
but for the most part this is the most
annoying and incessant batman movie for
me these movies a big part of it is the
villains and those iconic turns what are
people gonna do with the role and as
much as i like to see tommy lee jones
really stretch his legs and play a very
out there comedic role he and jim carrey
just create this dissonant loud annoying
presence on screen that only multiplies
when they get together i didn't grow up
with this movie i saw this movie later
than most of the 90s batman movies i
don't really have a strong childhood
connection to jim carrey so for me i'm
just watching jim carrey do a jim carrey
and it doesn't ever coalesce into the
movie for me so yeah not as fun as it
could be though i like the flying grace
and stuff and i like vel kilmer so well
he missed out on some good toys at the
fast food place where toys were born
with he was broken i remember all the
commercials so number 12 for me would
have to be justice league now i'll be
honest when i first watched this i
thought it was a lot of fun and i still
think there's definitely fun to be had
with this film i even like the batman
introduction here with the gotham city
it looked cool to me a little ridiculous
but i i was able to see past a lot of
the flaws when i first saw it now when i
try to watch it it's just almost
impossible because i know too much of
what happened with this film and then
you've seen zack snyder's justice league
you're like wow that's a genuinely great
film that'll be on this list and then i
look at this one and and it just it's
just so horrible now it's so weird to
just go from you know what i actually
kind of defend this movie to oh no this
is kind of rough so yeah the next one on
my list surprise surprise is batman and
robin i did grow up with this movie so
maybe there's some rose colored glasses
from that compared to batman forever
this movie is just a more consistent
watch for me i actually do enjoy uma
thurman and arnold schwarzenegger as the
villains and hey i mean george clooney
might not be the best batman but i get
where they were going and i like some of
his shades of the character and if we're
harkening back to that 66 flavor this
one was much less annoying to me than
the previous film and also too for as
garish and campy as the movie is like
some of the bane stuff is actually kind
of unsettling and disturbing to me so
because of that it takes on a bit more
of that gothic quality and there is some
camp that i do enjoy about this movie so
yeah not like miles above batman forever
but i would certainly probably put this
on sooner all right so that would be the
category of the batman movies we don't
like now let's move on to the batman
movies we do like
so for number 11 i think we have the
same one here which would be the 66
version of batman this movie is
genuinely a lot of fun the amount of
different gadgets and bat transportation
devices
that shark repellent baby i think it
does a really good job at what it sets
out to be and it lays the groundwork for
what the schumacher movies would try to
do but if you're going to have a bunch
of villains who are all sort of at 11 at
least you can kind of tell them apart
and it does feel authentically like a
comic strip of the time which is the
most appropriate for the time it was
made in so it's not at odds with itself
for me and it is yeah quite fun and
enjoyable love adam west and burt ward
together it shouldn't work but it works
but it works another one that we happen
to be aligned with but i feel like for
different reasons john and i know each
other's list but we don't know the
specifics of batman
1989. so for me michael keaton is he's
good i like i'm excited for michael
keaton to return for the flash but i'm
more excited about that because of the
roles i love michael keaton for outside
of batman i love the style of this movie
i love the aesthetic i love the music
this feels like i've stepped into a
frank miller graphic novel and jack
nicholson uh he is fun i feel like over
the years with getting like jokers that
don't feel like the actor is playing
himself have you kind of put down the
repetitive viewing experience of jack
nicholson for some people not everyone a
little bit for me i don't really get
that invested in the plot or the
characters it kind of falls a little
flat for me in terms of the enjoyment
but i still also like looking at it from
beginning to end yes there are some
selective scenes that i do truly really
enjoy that do generate some emotion but
for the overall experience i'm just i'm
more observant with the movie that's
exactly
exactly the word i was gonna go with as
i don't get really pulled in or swept up
i observe it and at times i'm like wow
i'm super appreciating this or yeah
that's a beautiful image and overall
there's just later work that will fill
that gap for me yeah that's good put it
so number nine for me would have to be
go back to my prizes i'm sorry can we
remix the audio
now when this movie first came out i was
a major defender of this in fact one of
the first videos you ever did was haters
why we love the dark knight rises in
repeat viewings over the years the film
has just gone down for me quite a lot i
think bane is such an underrated
performance weirdly iconic as and as
much as we mean this [ __ ]
i still feel like he doesn't get enough
credit for being such a great villain i
love a lot of the visuals like if you
have a blu-ray player with the right tv
you pop in that blu-ray watch those imac
shots they are still beautiful the music
is awesome there's elements of like the
tone and atmosphere that i still really
enjoy and i like anne hathaway a lot but
there's just so many writing choices
especially in its second half once we
reach like ground zero territory with
the film it just bug me more and more
and more and just get worse the more i
think about it and every time i watch it
you guys probably already know what the
hell those are you've heard them put it
out for so many years and maybe as a
movie solely on its own it's better but
as a viewer i can't help but view it as
the third installment in two much better
films fair enough my number nine uh
remember we're in the part of the list
where we like all this stuff my number
nine is batman v superman the ultimate
edition massive massive improv it took a
film that i hated and made it a film i
like i really enjoy a lot of the
characterizations even lex luthor i'm in
the minority who especially in the
extended edition kind of sees where he's
coming from and ultimately it's just i'm
not as attached to this iteration of
these characters and i think there are
zack snyder films i like better and
batman films i like better so you know
it's it's definitely a marked
improvement i definitely have good
feelings towards it there's just a lot
of other movies i would watch sooner
than that
sure snyder hater huh that's what we
have here that's right man close the
snyder verse all right now for my list
we have entered the categories of batman
movies i love i'm gonna keep this one
short but i really love this one a lot
the lego batman movie it is hilarious
like it's a great damn comedy the
voiceover work is excellent the
animation is astounding and it weirdly
in some ways feels like one of the
purest batman movies despite how many
jabs it takes on itself it really knows
the batman world from the comics from
the shows to the movies it feels like it
sets out to honor them while also poking
fun at itself and it has so much heart
and there's cool action i i genuinely
think this is a fantastic film and i
really hope that one day we can get the
lego batman movie part two because uh
willard is excellent he's batman and
this movie is also my number eight so uh
yeah everything you just said pretty
much is a loving parody that also speaks
to how much they know the mythology and
all the different iterations of that it
borders on being maybe a little hyper
kinetic for my taste but that's about
the only complaint i have about it's so
much fun and yeah i would love to see a
sequel so i think our number sevens are
the same here which would be zack
snyder's justice league now if we were
just doing a dceu film ranking list this
would actually be higher but because
this is a batman list that's how i'm
sort of putting the optics around it
that's why it falls at number seven i
think this is a wonderful film i love it
i've seen it three times now i'm never
bored one second during this experience
i think it's beautiful yeah hashtag
we're sort of snide reverse we got a
multiverse going on let's do it guys but
the reason why falls on number seven is
because this is like obviously more of a
justice league movie an ensemble piece
and there's all these other much bigger
pieces to the whole thing i also feel
like my biggest takeaways with this
movie are not really about batman while
i think ben affleck is excellent as
always the way he carries over from bbs
to this one is solid however i mainly
think about like cyborg and flash like
other elements of the film and i'm like
oh yeah but he's still good but he's not
one of the top things i actually think
about when thinking about this movie
yeah it's fair i mean for my taste i
don't have a tremendous attachment to
ben affleck's batman bruce wayne but
this was my favorite performance of his
and the most pathos i thought he brought
to out of the most i got connected to
him and i really do like the journey of
showing how and why the justice league
needs bruce what function he serves for
them and all that like i thought that
was nicely laid out here so yeah like
really quality but ultimately yeah you
come out with a lot of other things to
think about yeah he's a good job at
playing a lead but ultimately knowing
the lead position is to support the
other characters 100 so my number six
would have to be batman returns so this
one did everything batman 89 did but so
much better in my opinion i think the
primary leg up that this film has is
that they really let tim burden do so
much more of what tim burton is great at
doing having that level of much less
restraints is really palpable with this
movie i think michelle pfeiffer is
excellent i also really buy the
chemistry between her and michael keaton
chris walken is a great addition danny
devito is excellent in here this movie
is funny sometimes scary sometimes
uncomfortable sometimes sexy beautiful
it's gothic fact might should be higher
it's a great film i genuinely think this
is a great movie every time i re-watch
it the older i get the more i like it
for some reason yeah batman returns
excellent film so yeah my number six
would have to be the dark knight rises i
agree with a lot of what you said
obviously i like it more than you there
is some stuff that still sticks in my
mind that is still iconic that i still
really love and i still think really
nicely incorporates the history of the
world nolan built obviously bane is
iconic but yeah as his movies go it's
much blockier there are like a million
plot threads that feel way more chaotic
somehow than the dark knight does so
yeah it's the most flawed of the nolan
trilogy but i still think it turned out
pretty solid overall and i do like how
it rounds out the trilogy even though i
admit it could be better and more
graceful etc so my number five would
actually be batman be superman ultimate
edition not just because it is an
improvement over the theatrical cut like
does that aid i'm sure it does in some
subconscious way i genuinely love this
version i love the build that it does
and pretty much most of the flaws
including the martha moment
just makes sense in this version i love
the piece that this is and in terms of
batman i think the reason why i put this
as number five is because this dude is
easily the most formidable like in my
opinion he could kick all the other
batman's asses all right i think he's so
badass that warehouse fight is easily my
favorite batman fight on live action
that's been done to date big that makes
it higher on the list is especially
because of who ben affleck is as batman
here i love the combination of both his
bruce wayne and his batman because bruce
wayne is definitely like cocky has
attitude like i don't give a [ __ ] but
still feels like really haunting broody
and dark you can see how people wouldn't
suspect him be batman but you could also
see how this guy could also be batman if
someone were to tell you that while he
is more willing to like kill if
necessary in this world that is
established it works for me i know for
some people it's a big no-no for me i
actually don't mind it elements of it
feel like an alt universe almost thomas
wayne-esque from flashpoint for me and
yeah he's just like the most badass
version
in my personal opinion so going into the
top five i've deliberated on where to
put this one in particular and it's
partly landing at number five because
it's the one i've seen the least
recently but batman mask of the phantasm
is such a wonderfully orchestrated movie
and talking about like lego batman a
movie that's geared toward families more
broadly i love that this is coming out
of the animated series which is already
renowned for its sophistication and its
darker themes it builds perfectly on top
of that it has all these rich gothic and
noir but also very comic book aesthetics
and you got to give it props for
introducing a really iconic villain for
the movie itself and really playing off
of those film noir and femme fatale
themes and also utilizing the rogues
gallery and a really wonderful and in
some cases some people would argue
definitive way depending on the day this
might land even higher on my list
because i just love the world of the
animation the look of it and how it
really washes over you and i would kill
to see this on a big screen alright so
yeah my number four on the list is
actually batman mask of the phantasm a
thousand percent everything that you
said the thing that i would add on to it
is that in terms of all these movies in
some ways this might actually be the
most quintessential most apt depiction
of bruce wayne batman for a feature film
i think it is pitch perfect in that
regard i love the flashback elements and
how they use that to better serve the
present-day storytelling seeing how he
became batman his relationship with
andrea obviously had a connection with
the villain phantasm and the conflicting
choices that are presented truly feel
conflicting i love the mood that this
one strikes everything about the gothic
elements that you were talking about the
musical score here is also wonderful
from the very opening and it's honestly
pretty scary you know as a kid there was
like some kind of terrifying moments
there are certain deaths that feel very
haunting mark hamill as the joker i
think is so enjoyable and i'm so
surprised we have heard nothing about
doing a live action phantasm movie yet
it'll happen someday all right so my
number four batman returns i won't say
too much because i pretty much agree
with everything you said but yeah this
was one i saw later on in life and uh
have enjoyed every time and since
increasingly and i love just the general
theme of unity among freaks that this
movie explores and yeah it feels like it
delivers on what i was hoping the 89
film would it feels way more authored by
tim burton i get sucked into it nothing
is left without some kind of character
and some kind of detail mixing you know
those gothic comic book aesthetics with
the more sort of strange silent movie
stuff that tim burton likes i absolutely
adore michelle pfeiffer's catwoman danny
devito's penguin just reminded me how
great of an actor he can be especially
in character roles i love the addition
of chris walken as max shrek i love this
movie more every time i watch it alright
so number three for me would have to be
batman
begins this is a great movie
yeah all right it's a great movie uh it
is so much fun it's exciting to me it's
like just a great blockbuster film
because it's character-driven but it
escalatingly gets more entertaining and
more rousing you know like that
introduction of the batmobile and his
first time that man and i think also
while i would give the leg up to mask of
phantasm in terms of like the perfect
split and duality of batman and bruce
wayne this to me is the best origin tale
told of batman and it also captures this
great nuanced relationship with alfred
the relationship performs with lucious
fox i might get crap here i actually
prefer katie holmes over maggie
gyllenhaal in the role of rachel fair
enough and i think uh christian bale's
voice is actually really cool in here do
i look like a guy i do think there's a
lack of scarecrow here why i always
crave for more killian murphy in that
film whenever i watch it liam neeson is
good the racial goal in this film is not
my personal favorite thing but in terms
of your origin tale of batman and the
world created in the han zimmer score
and all those goodies this one was
excellent and i also think that
christian bale's bruce wayne is probably
my favorite i personally prefer the
one-two combo of bruce wayne batman with
ben affleck but in terms of just
isolating bruce wayne christian bell is
my favorite i couldn't agree more number
three is also batman begins for me and i
think of all the nolan movies this is
the one that most evenly bridges the gap
between graphic novel and gritty cinema
feel and it really creates a heart too
yeah and it really creates an
anticipation for what's to come it feels
like the most graphic novel that his
movies get gotham feels the most gothamy
out of all of his movies it's not too
big it's not too small it's very noir
and uh and yeah you can never have too
much killian murphy
all right so you know if you reveal
number two you automatically know what
number one is the reason why john i know
each other's list because i feel like we
had to know what this were all different
before we had everything ahead of this
damn video we're just gonna say number
two and number one at the same time
because once you say number two you know
what number one is so number two
after watching this three times on three
different types of theaters and screens
i could confidently say my number two is
the batman as would you likewise and so
number one would have to be
batman forever go on for a joke yeah god
did we ran out
look we've talked extensively about both
of these films
the main reason why i would give a leg
up on the dark knight re-watchability
also the heart that that movie has and
it is just generally more exciting of a
film so there's definitely qualities of
the batman that i way prefer over the
dark knight especially if it's detective
elements i prefer that version of batman
the easiest way i could put it is what
i've heard a lot of people say and i
couldn't agree more with this sentiment
i think the batman is a damn near
perfect batman movie and is a better
batman movie than the dark knight is but
i think the dark knight is overall a
better film just like by a tiny bit for
me and more enjoyable purposefully
yeah well it's still a blockbuster while
having all of that grit and heft and
realism that they're trying to inject
but especially when you watch the batman
you're like oh the christopher nolan
movies are more graphic novelly than i
gave them credit for and yeah the batman
to me speaks to certain elements of just
cinema tradition and certain character
themes that appeal very directly to me
outside of the comic book sphere but
yeah when you look at it it's like i'll
never forget the experiences i won't
forget the experiences with the batman
either but with the dark knight it was
such a moment everyone was there we
camped out for hours we saw it like 16
times in the theaters and it's held up
across all of that it's an iconic movie
and it's hard to top and yeah it's like
if you're just a cinephile i would say
maybe the batman's your movie but for
the overall scope and spectrum and
comprehensiveness everything you have to
factor in yeah for everything across the
history of the character on screen i
feel like yeah the dark knight nails
that stuff and it is iconic and
definitive and all that and granted you
know you obviously think so much more
about joker than you would batman in
that film and that's actually why i
would say the first 15 to 20 minutes of
the batman is the best 15 to 20 minutes
of any batman movie and i would give
that over the dark knight because while
i think that is a solid opening scene
prologue for the dark knight that's a
joker scene yeah first 15-20 minutes of
the batman that is pure batman well the
batman is i think the one batman movie
where
among the first topics of discussion is
batman bruce wayne robert pattinson etc
whereas the other movies it's usually a
villain first and batman is notable but
yeah like he is the most like focal
everyone's like gotta talk about him and
i still like his journey and the thing
is that's really hard to talk for me is
the scene with joker and batman in the
interrogation room in the dark knight
that's just so hard to top because it's
so iconic and it's just hits all the
feels like i watch the dark knight 12
times in totals in the theaters i'm
gonna watch the batman a fourth time but
i think i'm good
yeah i was gonna say which which near
three-hour experience flies by quicker
yeah
yeah you know i think i uh i can put
this down first
[Music]
yeah for sure and plus i mean dark
knight has way more just legitimate imax
moments too which are insanely
breathtaking to behold all right guys
well that's our list for the batman
movies what would your ranking be
obviously you gotta let us know down
below put quite a lot of thought into
the structure of this one so thanks for
sticking around with us and uh yeah this
is objective none of it is subjective
i'll talk to you guys soon